muchas gracias por la invitación a este
lindo país yo soy chilena y vengo con
mucho amor a compartir dos elementos que
ustedes como personas hermanos tienen y
voy a contar mi historia del como le
hace en el switch on como yo me
convierte una persona más inteligente y
vivo con dignidad
quizás ignacio y adiós la plataforma
para darle a conocer como la mujer puede
emprender científicamente emprendimiento
a nivel en inglés no solamente economía
es una forma de vivir en mi caso me tocó
vivir en extrema pobreza nací indígena
pobre y mujer de acuerdo al estudio
científico 200 años para salir de la
pobreza
en khyber match se puede dentro de ese
contexto lamentablemente y eso es que
quiero prometer en las niñas de colombia
de latinoamérica no tienen que dejar su
casa para emprender para ser feliz
solamente tienen que darse cuenta que
tienen inteligencia y dignidad
me dieron estos minutos para contarles
cómo lo hice
y espero que le prendan ampolletas y a
todos ustedes no entonces a mí me tocó
de alguna forma declararme burra tonta
por los primeros 21 años porque nací en
la legua santiago/chile lo cual porque
no podía articular mis necesidades y
dentro de mi contexto la verdad es que
mi rendimiento escolar era muy pobre
entonces sacándome 20% de la marca 10%
esta es burra pero era muy buena para
vender en la calle tenía esta
inteligencia emocional decirte app o
cliente 10 por mil y logré tener esa
inteligencia emocional pero además
descubrí que tenía un cerebro pero mi
contexto educacional no me lo permitió
activar porque como no rendía igualmente
con el resto era tonta e incluso yo me
empecé a encontrar son re tonta entonces
pero como pasa piola como se dice en
chile nadie se dio cuenta que observaba
y esa era la primera característica de
una científica de observar de estar
calladita
entonces lo que descubrió mediante la
disciplina fue como quería ir yo a
estudiar y mis padres lamentablemente no
era un vocabulario día a día mi madrina
me invitó a ser técnico paramédico tuve
tantas desgracias que ustedes seguro que
van a encontrar en redes sociales todas
mis desgracias pero no quiero hablar de
mis desgracias quiero hablar de la
oportunidad que tenemos ser inteligentes
indignos entonces el cerebro humano lo
están mirando en este momento tiene el
hemisferio izquierdo derecho si hay
profesionales de solución a dar cuenta
en estos momentos que se pueden tocar y
está aquí para que no sepan no está aquí
está aquí ok no está aquí
entonces qué significa eso que en la
inteligencia de una más activa aquí y
como latinoamérica tenemos así de grande
nuestra inteligencia no tenemos que
unirlo porque hay trans parte de corazón
pero no hay trasplante de esto entonces
con esto le voy a dar un ejercicio
específico la creatividad tecnológica en
la transformación viene de nosotros
latinoamericanos la mayoría de los que
están sentado en silicon valley son de
india en latinoamérica o asia por qué
porque somos nosotros nos encanta el
movimiento la música no ya vimos una
emprendedora musical hoy con la ciencia
podemos introducir esta inteligencia
digna en la era digital entonces cómo se
hace esa transformación educándose hoy
hay una democracia digital que tú puedes
estudiar concepto en profundidad no
tienes que ir a la universidad tienes
que tener un estilo de vida de
aprendizaje de emprender de saber que
habla mi autoridad acerca de
discernimiento
qué sé yo yo dije ah lo acabo de
aprender un mes atrás porque a mí me
educaron en australia pero mike fincke
es en inglés hay fin que en inglés
picosa y falso sophisticated
ah me entendieron gracias un aplauso a
usted mismo
entonces lo que no aprendí en mi país
lamentablemente por haber nacido pobre
mujer indígena tuve que irme australia a
los 21 y llegué a australia y llegué a
mi jardín donde me convertí en la
primera enfermera en informática en
salud en australia y dentro de eso me
quedé y tanto el cuento que empecé a
representar disciplinadamente a mis
científicos que están en esa foto la
mayoría de ellos son arriba de 70 años
una de las más jóvenes y la única
chilena que representa esa academia
científica tengo tanto aplauso
gracias y dentro de eso escrito la
transferencia desde english and spanish
lamentablemente con mucho respeto a
nuestros gobiernos se han dado cuenta
pero hay una brecha social de 20 a 30
años en conocimiento pero mi equipo hoy
y todos ustedes de seguro que están aquí
queremos emprender en traer ese
conocimiento no cometen los mismos
errores mi doctorado fue acerca de
errores humanos en el cuidado de las
personas y descubrí dentro de esa
ciencia que la inteligencia
organizacional puede evitar el 80% del
error humano el error humano es
solamente el 20% entonces cuando usted
va al trabajo y se siente mal su
instinto le dice es porque su jefe no
está haciendo bien el trabajo no está
creando una cultura gentil y dentro de
esa cultura en salud sobre todo en
nuestro en nuestro continente el
paciente pierde su dignidad en el
proceso esos mitos libros yo los regalos
al final está mi correo si alguien lo
quiere que lo mande en pdf porque la
editorial chilena me estafó acerca
también para que usted sepa es
latinoamérica lamentablemente pero ya se
terminó el contrato y los puedo regalar
así que por favor anoten se complete
entonces quiero que es inteligencia
artificial solamente para que ustedes no
se sientan intimidados porque yo la
tontorrona cuando termine mi mi
doctorado y yo necesito saber que como
unir estos 53 software hice un
postdoctorado de inteligencia artificial
para la seguridad del paciente pero qué
significa en realidad eso fue hace 18
años atrás o es una rama de ciencias
computacionales que estudian modelos de
cómputo capaces de actividades propias
de los ser humanos de tú tú tú los que
están en línea también que significa la
máquina está replicando nuestro cerebro
lo algoritmo reprex pero la conducta
humana si tenemos pobreza humana hoy que
es aprended ahora no tiene acceso es una
actividad humana que está causando la
pobreza no es la tecnología no es el
vecino es tu irresponsabilidad de no
activar tu inteligencia y la dignidad
tuya y el otro
es hora de despertar la conducta humano
se está replicando en la economía
digital y tenemos que evitar eso porque
tus datos están siendo vendidos sin tu
consentimiento entonces la ciencia
necesita entrar a tener marcos jurídicos
y acabo de terminar un magíster en
derecho me encanta estudiar me siento
ignorante perdón
y en base al razonamiento y conducta
como somos la latina en el razonamiento
pensamos con esto con esto o con esto
aquí
nos falta más usar este gran regalo de
dios unir todo como un sistema holístico
para la dignidad humana y en eso les
pido que la conducta nunca la perdamos
la esencia de ser latinas pero si el
razonamiento tiene que entrar en un
marco económico político y social con la
misma esencia que los pueblos nativos
necesitan saberlo y con ellos lo invito
a estudiar esta ciencia que se llama jon
quien completa la introducción yo hice
mi doctorado con esa técnica pero hay un
factor humano que las máquinas han
podido capturar es la confianza de speed
of trash y lamentablemente con mucho
respeto y yo tengo una mirada muy sureña
no nací en chile me fui a australia y
luego por ambición humana me fui a
trabajar al banco mundial no pero me
sentí así como incómoda y la economía
está vendiendo la inteligencia y la
dignidad humana
me fui al tiro al sur
porque mi confianza es ayudar a esta
evolución social yo no soy parte de una
economía bruta sin inteligencia y sin
respetar la dignidad humana y yo sé que
ustedes escuchando hoy pueden hacer esa
diferencia si llegan a la casa y le
dicen mamá te estoy ayudando y es tu
hijo no tú estás ayudando a tu hogar
tenemos que dejar esa cultura machista
pero no es culpa del gobierno no es
culpa de la sociedad es responsabilidad
tuya porque tú factor humano tiene que
estar basado en la persona no en nombre
o mujer y es por eso el gimnasio hablaba
también se sentía cómodo con su madre
porque obviamente se siente reconocido
como persona no por sus genitales
entonces dentro de esto como medimos el
impacto hoy en la transformación digital
y gracias por todos los auspiciadores
porque igual aceptaron mi discurso que
bastante diferente es el impacto
tecnológico que estamos haciendo hoy
necesitamos estar todos incluidos no
estar enojados del sistema y como decía
muy muy bien diana esto tiene que ver
con disciplina y amor si tu corazón no
tiene amor tu cuerpo no tiene amor tú
vas a estar peleando constantemente
desde el daño haya sido pobre yo soy
víctima del sistema entonces tiras acá
está la voy a
porque quiere decir que necesitas
terapia necesitas encontrarte a ti misma
y nosotros somos seres de amor si no hay
amor en ti no puedes dar amor tienes que
trabajar en el tú en tu comunidad y en
la sociedad entonces este impacto lo
estamos midiendo a nivel de economía
digital lo cual tú al tener una
tecnología puedes hacer una
transformación de conducta en mi caso
para salvar la vida salud significa
salvación y en ese aspecto yo no hago
una interrupción económica a costa de
los pobres sino que es a costa de una
invención tecnológica que ayuda a mi
nación y mi comunidad a seguir
progresando su dignidad qué significa
esto significa que el líder el impacto
tiene que acabarse en tu cuánto tienes
en la cuenta bancaria el impacto se mida
cómo se respeta la dignidad humana y los
abogados saben eso porque toda
constitución de país tiene la dignidad
humana pero cuando llega a la práctica
la violamos constantemente
entonces cuál es mi posición identidad
propia hoy yo soy chilena todo hay que
irme de mi país 25 años para encontrarme
a mí misma
hoy soy decana de una facultad de
ciencias de la salud de la universidad
católica de temuco con 2000 estudiantes
y tenemos el grupo más fuerte valiente
los mapuches que creen que mantener su
cultura es importante y con eso quisiera
pedir un aplauso de ustedes a mi
comunidad mapuche de temuco y vamos que
podemos entregar amor
[Aplausos]
entonces cómo se ve nuestro hogar en la
arquitectura digital es esto lo que yo
hago como ciencia y preparo cursos
diplomados magistris doctorado es la
base hay un proceso todo de tarros y
computadores pero ahí no hay actividad
humana la gobernanza por eso trabajé 20
año el sector público de australia es
tener auspicio de los ejecutivos
tenemos que tener liderazgo liderazgo
femenino masculino de niños todos
tenemos que ser protagonista de nuestra
dignidad para luego entrar a procesos de
calidad sanitario no podemos vender más
educación o salud porque son derechos
humanos básicos de cualquiera persona
basta de vender esos derechos humanos
tenemos que educarnos para proteger la
salud y educación de nuestras personas
por qué es tan importante esta
arquitectura porque protege por
estándares y puede parar a compañías
grandes de vender tus datos sin tu
consentimiento tu libertad de darle
consentimiento depende de ti no de una
compañía
entonces cuáles son los indicadores
clave si usted dicen habrá algún
científico que abra una mamá que quiere
cocinar bien en la casa y llevarse bien
y parar los conflictos generalmente las
mujeres no expresan su descontento con
violencia ellas no son las que están en
la cárcel mayormente ellas no son las
que violan sexualmente al otro sino que
hay un patrón acá que de alguna forma
revienta nuestra sociedad es un alan
análisis de la raíz de la causa porque
mi mamá anda tan enojada tienes que
preguntarte definir el por qué ella está
enojada entender su contexto quizás
porque no tiene agua electricidad para
cocinar y luego entrar e identificar
exactamente misma más está un poquito
enferma porque no está caminando tanto
quizás su peso le estaba causando daño y
luego tener acciones correctivas con el
análisis y diálogo a esa persona o
paciente no y ahí luego comenzamos a
vivir en un bienestar
constante esto no es una varita mágica
del de afuera estás en sus corazones en
su cerebro y en su propia
excepción comprensión del mundo entonces
la innovación por primera vez lo está
permitiendo en la era digital la
transformación digital permite por
primera vez que tú eres tienes el poder
de cambiar tu vida y vivir con dignidad
donde tú quieras vivirlo entonces aquí
están mis contactos saque sus cámaras
para que me saquen fotos y pidan por
correo su respectivo libro porque estos
conocimientos son gratis hoy por primera
vez en el mundo
en el mundo digital tú tienes acceso a
expertos directamente y con eso si tú
crees que tu dignidad y tu inteligencia
no está siendo respetada mándale un
twitter mándalo knister gran hagamos
tendencia con este evento tan especial
para crear una conciencia y visibilidad
de que nosotros todos somos inteligentes
incluso con personas con patologías
cognitiva un niño síndrome dragón tiene
más cariño más grande que personas que
tienen piquete y con eso podemos
celebrar la vida juntos entonces yo
necesito ahora en este último minuto que
tengo
para quien está dispuesto a cambiar este
respeto a la dignidad necesito que se
paren y digan yo puedo vamos que se
puede
y vamos cambiando muchas gracias no se
pasaron los quiero mucho
[Aplausos]